forte pascal deschamps il y a dix ans il
avait frappé un grand coup avec meurtre
dans un jardin anglais
un polar east éthique et énigmatique
peter greenaway n'a rien perdu de son
goût pour l'étrange témoins the baby à
mâcon le bébé de mâcon où la chronique
de la naissance d'un enfant dans la
bonne ville de mâcon au xviie siècle
une naissance que famille eglise
s'empresse de présenter comme
miraculeuse un public crédule
depuis paul ii makoun il y a trois idées
dans mon film à l'expo celle de
l'exploitation mercantile des enfants
celle de la crédulité des spectateurs
devant n'importe quel spectacle et celle
des similitudes entre l'église et le
terrain
et aujourd'hui on ne peut plus croire
quand les bons sont toujours récompensés
les mauves est toujours puni
en revanche ce sont toujours des
innocents qui payent
depuis quelques temps déjà peter
greenaway situe l'action de ses films
dans le passé mais c'est dit il pour
mieux parler de thèmes tout à fait
contemporain